[Music]
destruction at a southeast valley
grocery store the front awning of a la
bonita supermarket collapsed injuring
four and leaving a massive amount of
debris we've been following the story
throughout the day madison kimbrough is
live with what we know about the cause
and where they go from here madison
yeah it's hard not to notice the scene
denise we're giving you an aerial view
from the parking lot here on eastern and
desert inn look at the area you can see
all of this debris you can see wood
bricks cement all over insulation and
metal pipes this awning collapse
happened just after six this morning
clark county fire rushed to the shopping
center there are initial reports of
people trapped in the rubble but we did
get an update of four people were
transported to the hospital all with
non-life-threatening injuries i spoke to
shoppers who can't believe what they saw
but they're glad that no one was
seriously hurt
one of the first mexican
latin stores you know in the community
it's been here for a very long time
we've been i've been here since the
early 90s
and i mean this is the one that
everybody knows
the the local bonita where you could get
everything you needed
and it's just very devastating i hope
they're able to bring it back up
i did get a statement from armando
martinez the general manager of la
bonita supermarkets he said quote our
desert in location will remain closed
until further notice all employees will
be given the day off fully paid and
offered any medical or emotional support
services if needed once they are ready
they will be relocated to another
location until we can reopen desert in
stores currently there are no estimates
on damages and the cause like we
mentioned is still unknown but there
were 45 personnel on site this morning
all through the day for this incident so
it is extensive and we will be giving
you live coverage all through the night
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now